there's a lot of misinformation about
the mining in bitcoin
they are not going to buy bitcoin until
this esg issue is resolved
period let me let me be very blunt about
this
i would say right now less than one
percent of global institutions and
sovereign funds have anything to do with
crypto
in any way
[Music]
all right so kevin you are raising the
need to know the provenance if you will
of bitcoins and advocating for clean
coins for
a while now certainly an issue that's
been taken up by elon musk he's recently
tweeted that he's having active
discussions
with bitcoin miners regarding the
sustainability of the digital coin
why is the idea of a green coin if you
will
so important to bitcoin's growth as an
asset class
because it matters to institutions and
the way you have to think about this
there's a lot of excitement within the
crypto community particularly around
bitcoin
that it's to the moon you've heard that
expression many times and that it won't
be long before it's a hundred thousand
dollars a coin
none of that's going to happen unless
the institutional market starts to
buy this as an asset class and for all
the hype and excitement and
all the you know discussions that have
been going on online and on social media
the truth is institutions haven't
touched this yet
not the real institutions not the
sovereign funds not the pension plans
very very few are involved in it and one
of the major reasons if not
the reason is that they all now have to
be compliant
to sustainability and ethics committees
and the way you have to look at that is
you know you've got let's say you're
managing 50 billion dollars
you're you're a sovereign fund and you
are concerned about
the long-term investment that's the
nature of what they do
and so you concern yourselves about the
issues that the people you're serving
care about and one of those
that has been coming and moving right up
the hip parade is sustainability esg
you've seen it happen at the corporate
level there's a very famous letter that
came out of larry think of blackrock
just
six months ago that really defined what
it meant to be sustainable and climate
change and all of these things
that people kind of ignored for a long
time but now at the institutional level
if you're sitting with a sustainability
committee on top of the investment
committee
you have to go through their filter
first and their filter
has been very clouded by this debate
around sustainability and coin mining
you know there's many miners
particularly in asia and other foreign
countries that actually
burn coal to make bitcoin well that's
not okay anymore and that's why this
debate has come to the fore
but but i say it's important and it's a
good thing because if we can resolve
this we can open up the floodgate
the log jam if you would of
institutional money that wants to
allocate to bitcoin so
i as a bitcoin owner want the
institutional
buyer to be my incremental buyer that
way i can see price appreciation we're
going to be stuck in a rut here
till we resolve this issue and i think
it's very important to have an open
forum about it and have a dialogue i
took a lot of criticism when i raised
this just a couple of months ago
now it's at the four of everybody's
discussions yeah it is and it's partly
uh the reason that we've had so much
volatility in bitcoin lately with
as i said elon musk saying he's not
allowing a tesla's to be purchased by
bitcoin because of those environmental
concerns
now seemingly addressing that issue uh
michael saylor
he tweeted after elon musk's tweet that
they've been meeting with bitcoin miners
and they now have this bitcoin mining
council which will promote
sustainability
so kevin what impact will this mining
council have
and in a way is a mining council
antithetical to the decentralized
ideology of bitcoin
well that is a very good question you've
really nailed the issue you've got the
original crypto community that is
steadfast holding to decentralization
they don't think they need a voice they
think that the overall
aggregate of all the people that are you
know want to be in the crypto business
or be owners of crypto coins and tokens
and everything else
they don't need to form a lobby group
and at the same time while they're
having that discussion new york turns
around
a few weeks ago and puts a moratorium or
at least threatens one for three years
on any bitcoin mining
and they have one of the most
interesting possibilities lots of
hydroelectricity that's not being used
around niagara falls etcetera and so
because the industry has no voice
it has no lobby it has no way to fight
back
when a single regulator a single state
or a municipality
basically bans bitcoin or tries to keep
capital away by threatening something
like this
there's nowhere to go all you have is a
barragement of
social media occurring but no
centralized voice or committee so i
applaud
anything that tries to aggregate the
thought process and this
there's many different forms being
proposed and in fact there's a really
big bit
of really big bitcoin conference here in
miami on june 4th and 5th
and this will be one of the topics
that's discussed because the world is
gathering here in miami
and we didn't know what the core issue
would be but certainly this is going to
be one of the big ones sustainability
esg institutional buying
is all part of it and i think the
pressure that elon must have felt when
he announced that he would take payment
in bitcoin
well a lot of institutions that are his
shareholders in tesla
that have provided him billions of
dollars of market capitalization
immediately jumped on him and said i'm
speculating when i say this but i'm sure
it happened
wait a second where did that coin come
from how was it mine how do you know it
wasn't mind
you know in an in in sustainable manner
or one that
wasn't sustainable at all and i think
that's the pressure that he felt to come
out and say wait a second i have to
rethink this
and i want to talk to miners remember
there's only two and a half million
coins left to be mined that's it
and so it depends on what happens to the
next two and a half million
versus all the coins that are out there
already and that's the dialogue the
industry is having right now but this
issue
is not going away it is not going away
and if we want to see price appreciation
whether it be on a green coin or a
sustainable coin
or the aggregate of already mined coins
we're going to need to solve for this
because the incremental buyer the
institution
is where the next trillion dollars worth
of interest is going to come from well i
look forward to seeing how that gets
resolved i too will be at the
bitcoin conference in miami looking
forward to that but kevin assuming
the sustainability issue is somehow
successfully addressed and we do get
more institutional interest
what do you then see as potential
existential threats to bitcoin because
it's a disrupter
combined with the d5 which we'll get
into later and
governments central banks traditional
institutions
they don't want to be disrupted so is
there anything that you see
coming from that end that can derail
crypto well let's see bitcoin
specifically sure let's stick with
bitcoin and let's just look at the last
90 days or even 60 days worth of
announcements
the chinese reiterated their concern
about the currency but didn't really
change policy
they just rattled their chain again
norway removed its tax credits to
bitcoin miners making it unprofitable to
mine there
and one of the largest miners basically
sold their assets there that all
happened in the last four weeks
then new york six weeks ago dropped
their bomb with their moratorium
so all of a sudden because the industry
has no voice and there's no one to cry
out and say look
there's some facts that are being
ignored here this is the problem there's
a lot of
misinformation about the mining of
bitcoin
but because there's no centralized voice
when that regulator in norway or in
new york or in any other jurisdiction
comes out and says we're going to ban
this because we think it's bad for the
environment
there's no push back and that's a huge
mistake
that bitcoin miners have done to
themselves and they've got to fix that
so basically when you think about why
bitcoin mining could be
good for the environment it's basically
the profit motive
in order to mine profitably you want the
lowest cost of energy you can get
and in many geographies in the world
that's sustainable
solar and wind certainly west texas
that's the case
and you see a lot of interest in going
there to tap into that
unused resource because so much of that
west texas wind
isn't being used by anybody it's not
even putting back into the grid so why
not monetize it in the form of bitcoin
which is a good use of that unused power
the same in northern alberta where you
can get
already flared off gas that's being
flared off now
and turn that into bitcoin these are all
sustainable in the sense that they're
creating value
and that's important there's nothing
wrong with that now of course there are
miners all around the world that are
burning coal
nobody wants that anymore which is why
you have institutions saying you've got
to show me
the difference between a coin mined that
way and one that's done sustainably
and i'll buy the sustainable mine coin
even if i have to pay a premium that's
the remarkable discussion that's going
on
because half the community says i want
fungibility i don't care where the coin
was mined or how it was mined
it has to be the same value as one that
was mined sustainably
i think we're going to go through a huge
debate on that on the fourth and fifth
but that's all part of the important
dialogue but my point is
bitcoin mining can be very good for the
environment
because it forces new innovation in the
creation of energy
okay point made but let's
disregard the whole environmental issue
for now and assuming
it's resolved i'm concerned about
governments central banks traditional
banking institutions
not liking this usurper something
that now comes and takes away their
monopoly from printing money we have
billionaire hedge fund manager ray dalio
says
he'd rather have bitcoin than a bond and
if the crypto space does continue to
attract investors attention
government bonds are going to see
significant outflows
governments are going to lose control
over their ability to raise money
and i don't think they're going to like
that very much kevin so does that lead
to government intervention is that a
concern for you
at all government government
intervention
and the regulatory environment
is always on the top of mind for me
because i have to
i have so many investments in financial
services companies
that i really care that we never in any
situation go follow the regulator that
is a very bad
waste of energy in terms of doing that
to yourself so compliance is my number
one cost
in all of my financial services
investments and i've learned to live
with that and i respect it and i
understand how valuable that is to be
compliant
versus not being compliant so when we
think ahead
of or where crypto's going to go let's
think of two paths
the the concern you have is talking
about it and i agree with you
as a currency that it would somehow
usurp the us dollar the
the standard currency the gold standard
for the world if you would in terms of
fiat currency
i don't think that's the long run for
bitcoin unless we're staying
specifically in bitcoin the reason
i own bitcoin is it's an asset like a
property
like a home like a piece of land like a
piece of art that is unique like a watch
that's one of a kind
to me it's not a currency it is not that
efficient
to use as a currency for a whole lot of
reasons
but as an asset like a like an acre of
land in a desirable geography
to me that's what it is when i buy my
coin i have no
intention of selling it i am going for
the long run to see if it appreciates
more than other hard assets because it
is a unique
asset in that respect so i'm not as
worried about
bitcoin specifically actually
being competitive with governments i
think they will come to the conclusion
that it is
an asset a hard asset a digital asset
and it's desirable for people that have
a long-term view and want to allocate in
my case
three to five percent waiting in that
asset just like i do real estate
or just like i do gold there's no
difference i still have a five percent
weighting in gold
in bullion and in etfs and i look at
bitcoin the same way
so yes you could be concerned but it is
such an inefficiency
if it's so inefficient as a currency
there's probably going to be something
that works
better now whether that's tied to the
chain or ethereum ends up being that or
whether there's a
actual u.s token as we already have
stable coins
there's many other solutions to this
problem but bitcoin's unique
it is what institutions want as a
property
as an asset and that's why i think it's
going to remain
that coveted so if it does remain
a coveted asset as a store of value
where do you think the price of bitcoin
can go in the next five years
i'm very bullish for how about i'll tell
you why i'm bullish
it goes back to your original question
it's a full circle
you asked about sustainability and the
interest of of
institutions i i talked to institutions
every day they are not going to buy
bitcoin
until this esg issue is resolved period
there's no flexibility
they have no choice they've already
decided that they're going to stay
cut within the covenants of their esg
committees i believe the industry
hears them you know just two months ago
when miners are trying to raise capital
in public markets
it was very easy to do so that is not
the case today
it has really become much more difficult
because every institution
that's approached to fund a new mining
operation regardless of the geography is
asking the same questions about
sustainability
around compliance around ethics and so
we're going to have this period this
pause
the pause that refreshes perhaps while
we work this out some solutions being
discussed and indeed i'm funding some of
these right now
is the idea of putting a wrapper on a
coin
that identifies it as a sustainably
mined green
coin now there's a huge debate going on
about that because it
takes away the fungibility of a coin
that was the number one bitcoin that was
ever mined
was probably not done in a sustainable
way but if this solves the problem for
the next two and a half million coins
and think about this there are many
miners that have kept their original
coins
on their balance sheets since day one
that have never sold them
and simply lend them out to get fiat to
pay their expenses
those coins were mined sustainably they
could also win that rapper
and so i want to be one of the people
investing in the technology that
provides wrappings for my coins
to prove that they were mined
sustainably
and that the institutions that i partner
with to actually
fund my mining operations and my
expansion into more mining operations
are doing so within the covenants of
their esg committees and that includes
sovereign funds
this dialogue is going on today and
there's at least two groups i know of
i'm involved in one of them
that is actually funding the development
of these green wrappers
and so look i'm happy to have the debate
with anybody but it's a solution that
really works
so what if you pay a small premium that
offsets the carbon
that you created making a coin
particularly if you're doing it on a
sustainable basis
you're not going to pay a lot for that
and yet you'll have what is so coveted
by institutions
a green coin so kevin if the stars align
and all of these issues are successfully
addressed what do you see
as the target price for bitcoin
in say five years time or even two years
time i'm trying to get to you to say
your number for me here
i think it will beat the equity indexes
that's what i think now you know in a
long period of time
seven to eight percent for equity
indexes i think this asset class will
outperform
over the next 10 15 years i invest for
the long term i have made my decision
currently
at a three percent weighting in bitcoin
i've done that because
i believe it will outperform the indices
over the next 10 years now the only
reason you would do that is you're going
to make a similar decision
i tell every institution that calls me
about this look it's a binary decision
the first decision is
are you going to hold bitcoin yes or no
second decision if it's yes follow that
decision tree it goes to
what weighting would you actually put in
bitcoin
in today's dollar value now if you're
most
institutions have a five to ten percent
waiting in gold and they have for
decades
gold was not mined sustainably it's one
of the most polluted things you can do
to the earth
and yet they ignored those issues when
they took the bullion out of the ground
now that bullion exists around the world
and it's a coveted asset
no different than a digital asset in my
view but they've got a five percent
waiting on average
so your decision is i'll take a five
percent waiting
in bitcoin but i have a sustainability
committee to answer to first
and i will only own coin that's mined in
my own facility or i'm a shareholder i
know it's done sustainably
or i will buy it with a wrapper that's
where i think we're going
and if that happens that way and the
institutional log jam opens up
and that capital starts coming in which
by the way is in the trillions of
dollars
i see bitcoin outperforming the stock
indices for a very long time but i'm not
betting the farm on it
i'm a three to five percent waiting
that's a rational decision for an
investor like me
and are you still maintaining that uh
five percent
in gold yes i am i am doing that because
i don't know with certainty
what's going to happen there now i get
into all these debates
even even this week with the crypto
community why are you holding any gold
at all
i'm holding gold because it's an asset
class that has been called that since
the romans minded
it has a very long history as an asset
one day after you and i are both dead
you'll say the same thing about bitcoin
but the point is it's very nascent it's
not even two decades yet and so we've
got a long way to go
but i have become a believer after being
a major skeptic for a long time i've
changed my mind
because the facts have changed and a lot
of that has to do with the regulators
in switzerland in france in germany in
australia in canada
where they have opened up the spigots to
allow this asset class to be owned
by institutional and retail investors i
want to quickly touch back
on the gold point is this physical gold
that you're still holding gold etfs are
there other precious metals
that you diversify whether is it five
percent just in gold
no i i'll disclose how i own it i own
two and a half percent waiting in
bullion which i pay for storage
and i own the gld which allows me to
balance the five percent every quarter
now the gld
also charges me fees but it's a liquid
asset that i can use to rebalance
now i could you know i could change that
weighting so two and a half percent gold
two and a half percent gld
it's worked for me for decades and i
simply rebalance every 90 days to a five
percent buy into five or sell down to
five
and it's been a you know a pretty good
asset for me over the last 20 years
all right well kevin you also like the
idea of green
coin in another sense if you will coins
that yield greenbacks
and uh to that end i understand you're
focusing on d5 decentralized finance you
tweeted that this is where the crypto
puck is going
so can you break that down for us yes i
can
um you know there i am sitting on
bitcoin and asking myself i don't get
any yield from gold and i certainly
don't get anything from bitcoin
and i i've got a pretty good team that
does research and due diligence for me
that works within my own
uh operating company and uh one of the
interns that i
i hired a few years ago is very very
advanced in his thought process on
crypto
and he came to me and said listen i'd
like to show you
some opportunities they're complicated
but
we are going to take our crypto assets
and loan them out into smart contracts
and i think i can get you between four
and eight percent yield on them
i said that's fantastic let's let's
explore here and i you know i took
different bets here's half a million
let's start with that
show me how you do it and you know you
know
i i love to be taught something new you
know i'm an old dog that can learn new
tricks
and i said listen kid that really works
let's make it bigger because i've got
more money to put to work that's
basically
zero return when you think about the
cash i hold right now
and that is getting nothing i'm
interested in finding out how i can use
it
to go into crypto and try and hedge my
bets and get
yield on it i'm going to be paid in you
know in usd coin and i can go back to
fiat if i wish
or different ways of doing it it's
complicated it involved setting up a
meta mask account and using my wallet
then i had to get my tax guys
to watch these transactions to make sure
i'm being reported
and being reporting my compliance on my
gains and my interest yields
because i don't want to be offside so it
got really complicated i had a lot of
people working on this
so i said to um the head of o'leary
ventures alex kenji
go find me a group go find me some
developers that can solve this problem
for me and i'll invest in them
because i want this to be simplified if
i'm trying to do this with this whole
team i've assembled here
there must be an easier way to do this
there has to be
where you could basically get a dap you
know a digital app that
that basically lets you do all of this
with the press of a button there has to
be a better way it sounds like a line
out of one of the shark tanks and there
and i found them i found them in
vancouver canada
a great team i did a lot of due
diligence on their private company so
i'm happy to disclose what i did
i basically bought a third of them and
they're my team now they're called d5
ventures
i'm an investor and i'm going to deploy
my capital there because they've solved
it for me
they're making the app so simple that i
can basically transfer over my digital
assets
be totally compliant even generate tax
returns
and send out my contracts and decide how
long i want them out there for what kind
of yield and what kind of risk i'm
willing to take because remember
i'm holding crypto with volatility the
reason i can make yield
using d5 is it has volatility so you
have to be willing to stomach that
volatility
for the periods you're opening these
smart contracts up and
that is going to be my platform for for
what i'm going to be doing
in my operating company and i'm happy to
be part of the community to invest in
them i put a lot of money to work there
and i think it's going to be a good
outcome i'm not the only person
investing in this there's others
but i enjoy a very large social media
following and i'm really proud of it
and i like to share what i learn with
everybody that's interested in it
and i'm going to try and you know bring
this company to the market
and say look here's one solution that's
my idea
and and i i'm really fascinated it's a
fantastic opportunity to deploy cash
i mean you can't make any interest
anymore with with fiat
this is a way to do it and yes there's
volatility
but you you said it right at the
beginning this is where the puck is
going this is where the capital is going
to invest in d5 is an immense
opportunity
and i certainly want to have a horse in
that race
all right so the larger trend is in d5
but unlike you if someone doesn't have
the capital to
launch their own d5 platform through a
private company how can an investor at
this point
until your's list shall we say gain
exposure
to the larger d5 trend and benefit how
can a retail investor
invest in the bigger defy movement
capitalize on that trend is it by buying
ethereum
well you could i mean but the thing is
there's many other alternatives and
other chains to work with
it's not just ethereum ethereum had a
massive correction it's very volatile as
well
i i think the biggest opportunity for me
as an investor is the fact that it's so
complicated to master defy it's so
it's so full of complications it hasn't
been simplified yet
there isn't really a retail product that
does it i hope to be one of the ones
that answers that
call and in doing so build a company
around it but i'm all about simplicity
i mean i don't want to have to read 15
pages to just figure out how to transfer
and set up a smart contract on a chain i
don't want to do that
i want someone else to do that for me so
i can just push a button
that's what i'm investing in we've
simplified so
many other aspects of financial services
over the last five years
why can't we do it in d5 and the answer
is we can
and that's why i'm putting money to work
well will my team be the best i have no
idea will it bring a great product
yet to be seen but i think i'm a great
mentor
and i have money to deploy and i have a
great number of people that are
interested
in giving me their sense of the
direction it should go into
and i just love being at the cutting
edge of this and
i want to invest in it why not stay
tuned is what i like to say
let's see where this goes i think it's
one of my most exciting investments and
i've got many
you have said though that ethereum is
digital silver to bitcoin's
digital gold are you still that hot on
ethereum as
digital silver then i own it it is
digital silver it will never replace
bitcoin as a coveted asset by
institutions
you know my feedback comes from talking
to institutions
i have not found first of all let me let
me be very blunt about this
i would say right now less than one
percent of global institutions and
sovereign funds have anything to do with
crypto
in any way they they have done nothing
so far
and so that's good and bad it's bad
because it really hasn't been you know
for all the hype that you hear about
every day saying oh institutions are
coming oh
here they come that's just a bunch of bs
that that is not happening at all and
larry figgs said as much just a few
weeks ago
and he's the largest asset manager on
earth and he's right
they're not going to play yet we talked
about the esg issue
but there's a lot of interest in in
decentralized finance
as an app as a methodology as where the
puck is going in terms of payment
systems and all kinds of other ideas
and so there is interest at the
institutional level and that's the
opportunity side of the ledger
and i think if i can be one of the
proponents that brings the institution
into the digital market specifically
what they are interested in is bitcoin
and we talked about it you know for this
last little while sustainably mind
ethically mine bitcoin that's what's on
the table right now
and i think you're going to hear that
when you come to this conference on june
4th june 5th
that's going to be certainly on my panel
the topic of discussion because i'm
going to be talking with the public
miners of the world
and they have the ear of the
institutions and vice versa
because they want to raise capital
expand their operations all over the
geography of the world
and do it in a sustainable way and
hopefully
out of that conference a voice will
emerge that can address some of these
institutional issues
it's a very exciting time in crypto but
it is nascent
anybody that tells you it's an
institutional product is full of you
know what
okay well i think kevin it's uh one of
the reasons that we've seen
an interest in bitcoin is stemming from
concern
about dollar devaluation which stems
from concern
about inflation and the fiscal and
monetary policies of the biden
administration because we have seen
an unprecedented level of fiscal and
monetary stimulus
money being printed and we don't even
use printers anymore so
that's even just an expression which is
meaningless
so where are you on the global
macroeconomic outlook
there's talk now that the fed is talking
about talking
about tapering what do you think about
that yeah they are talking about talking
about talking about tapering i get that
joke
um and yet today we see the ten-year at
a one-five handle on it i'm i'm a bond
guy i watch the 10 like a hawk
every morning i look at it it it is the
canary in the coal mine for inflation
you know talking about markets and and
because i think that's where your
question is going i'm trying to read
read your inflation question
my allocation starting last january went
from 50 50 and fixed income
to equities to 70 equities because my
feeling is we will see inflation
at some point in q4 and the reason i
feel that is we're stimulating the
economy in so many different ways at the
consumer level
now discussions about infrastructure all
of these ppp programs it's just money
flying out of a helicopter into the
economy in an unprecedented way
and yet i can measure the effect of that
by just looking at the tear sheets of my
30 plus
private companies i'm an investor and i
see their cash flows and their sales
each week
we are in an unprecedented growth
phase right now you know this this is
like the 50s the 1950s the late 1950s
early into the 60s
we're going to have six seven eight nine
percent gdp growth in q4
and so i think the equity numbers that
people put out the analysts keep
up you know keep upgrading their their
earnings estimates on companies
and the companies print and they beat
those up
estimates and it's going to continue to
keep happening which is why the markets
remain relatively buoyant yeah there's
some volatility in tech
because there's a concern about interest
rates but the growth rates of the
underlying tech companies remain
very very strong quarter after quarter
so i think this is just the
you know the classic garden variety
correction and what
is pause that refreshes i'm very
optimistic and constructive for equities
and the other reason going to your
inflation question is equities are a
good place to be when
inflation comes back because it gives
corporations pricing power
and indeed when you go back in history
and look at what happens when inflation
rears its ugly head
equities tend to do quite well as long
as it's not hyperinflation and we're
certainly not venezuela here in the us
yet
but if there is a a raising of rates
if there is a pulling back of of
buying assets do you think that the
markets are going to react with the
taper tantrum
you know the answer would be yes if it
was going to be a
a gap up you mean there were times in
the past where the fed moved
rapidly quickly decisively and in huge
50
50 increments which really hurts
equities
i just don't see that happening while we
have nine million people unemployed
it just i don't see it and also we have
a global economy now it's not so
isolated even though there's been a lot
of
you know inward looking about
repatriating a lot of manufacturing to
the u.s et cetera
it still remains a global economy and i
think
at the end of the day that sort of
tempers
rapid inflation returns you've got a lot
of stagnation in even japan still so
no that is not my number one concern um
i have diversified recently and put a 20
waiting in my equity into europe
everybody hates the european zip code
but i own
equities in swiss francs british pounds
euros
there's 50 companies there that are well
known in the domestic markets nestle
roche american tobacco
fantastic balance sheets strong power to
increase
prices during inflationary times stellar
distributions in terms of profits
almost a three percent dividend in some
cases i mean you know
why not own those at a time when even
the european regulators remaining very
very accommodative
and so my view is yes you can't for
the trouble is when people say i'm going
to take assets out of the market
they're trying to time the market and if
you had tried to do that over the last
18 months there were days
in our own domestic market where we had
between 7 and 11
swings intraday and if you weren't in
the market for those hours you missed 50
percent of the return of the year
and so i don't you know i i can't time
the market i've
i've tried to time the market everybody
tries it doesn't work
you've got to stay the course decide if
you're going to asset allocate for
example three percent to bitcoin
or you want to go to cash because you're
concerned but you'll make no return on
cash
in fact you'll have a negative return so
what is your number one
concern then
it really remains around the virus to be
honest with you
i want to know what happens in the back
end of the year
we're clearly going to get to a place
where 65 66
of the population is vaccinated in the
next 90 days
and then where do we go because if we
can't get
eighty percent compliance including ten
percent that have already been heard
inoculated by having
covet i think it it resurges
each fall just like the flu or influenza
pneumonia does and that's a bad
thing particularly if it's a variant
that's very viral
in terms of spreading or causes you know
more respiratory illness that ends up in
death
and so that could be a problem
there are countries like canada which
have been a disaster in managing
if you're in canada right now you can't
get a second shot the economy is
completely shut down
if you want to go and do business there
you have to go to an internment camp
where you're in prison for for some
period of time i don't know what they're
doing up there but it's a mess
but there's other countries in the same
boat but to see a g7 country like canada
in that situation tells you there's
still risk
in in the virus biden did one thing well
he promised
logistics to deliver viruses and he did
most people here
that want two shots have had them but
it's probably one of the only countries
in the world that that's the case
even in switzerland and france and
germany there's various versions i was
speaking to a fund manager today in
switzerland
they're not opening uh restaurants until
next monday and even so it's going to be
socially distanced and so they're they
really haven't
they're about six months behind the u.s
and canada is probably a year behind the
u.s and so those are still big problems
that could affect um what equity markets
do
so are there any significant changes to
your portfolio
that you make to adjust for this
covered recovering world are there any
sectors that you see will now be changed
in the long run here yeah i mean that's
a great question i did make some big
moves besides the move uh from 50 50
fixed income to equities to 70
equities i i have a rule that i do not
let a stock become more than five
percent waiting of the portfolio and i
never let a sector become more than 20
i've used that for decades for
diversification it's a discipline it
works for me because it really
helps protect you against drawdowns and
volatility
but the weight the sectors that i am
fully weighted in right now there are
two
healthcare and technology you know all
these discussions about all the
technological platforms that allowed us
to survive
and go digital i've watched these
technologies turn america into
america 2.0 a digital economy where
there's a tremendous
improvement in productivity take nike
for example a great global
example in five months they achieved
something they said was going to take
six years they went 50
direct to consumer all around the world
when you sell a product or service
direct to consumer you only have two
costs
customer acquisition cost and
manufacturing and delivery logistics
so your margins can be as high as 93 on
some products
versus going through the old traditional
retail which has fallen out of favor
so you've got all of these um
digitization platforms that have allowed
direct to consumer
and those are not work from home stocks
their work from anywhere stocks
the zooms the docusations this crowd
strikes
the shopify adobe all of these platforms
that continue to show
20 to 40 growth year over year that for
me that's a 20
waiting even though they're volatile
you're not going to find growth like
that anywhere else in the economy
and then finally my theory on health
care is look at the technology
the advancements that moderna and pfizer
did and others
that you know in 11 months brought out a
vaccine with new technology but
there's also a momentum within
governments particularly the us
government to repatriate
all aspects of health care that means
being bringing back generic drugs to
puerto rico to canada
to stateside to mexico so that they're
very close to the population and we
don't get stuck where we don't have
medical devices or ppp materials in the
next pandemic because i don't know when
covet 20 is coming or where it's coming
from
but i know it's going to come eventually
and we have to be set up for that so
the billions of dollars that will be
invested in health care is a very good
theme
so my overweighted or fully weighted is
technology
and it's it's healthcare and i've and
i've pulled back my horns from energy
hydrocarbons are falling out of favor
with institutional investors
you've seen that happen and i think they
will trade off and underperforming the
indexes for the next few years
all right well kevin to pay for all of
this uh stimulus the biden
administration wants to raise taxes
including corporate taxes and this is
now pushing the idea forward of a
minimum
global corporate tax rate u.s treasury
deputy secretary says he expects that
the g7 is
going to go along and back the proposed
15
plus global minimum corporate tax i know
you said you're a fan of investing in
europe well
france germany and italy they seem to be
fans of this minimum global corporate
tax rate japan also making some positive
comments
what do you think about it do you think
it'll get through
no i think the chance that happens is
zero here's why if the g7 do that to
themselves
the g20 will take advantage of it and
make sure all of that capital flows to
their jurisdictions
where they have lower no tax at all if
you think singapore
or those asian countries are going to
raise a minimum 15 percent
tax on corporations the chance of that
happening
zero they have such an advantage now so
you know
the point is people say oh there was a
time when america had a 30 plus percent
corporate tax rate it did just fine
that time has gone forever the reason is
now we have fungibility
you can work from anywhere you can put a
headquarter anywhere you have technology
that allows people to work from anywhere
they wish
why would you ever take take the
domestic example
i will never start a business in new
york massachusetts or california
ever until those guys get their act
together why would you ever put capital
work in a place that's so
mismanaged that their corporate tax
rates are already before the hike
uncompetitive i move them to texas and
to here in florida
this is where you this is where business
is done you don't do it in new york
anymore that's one of the reasons that
there's been such a huge increase in
valuations here
in real estate because everybody's
moving out of those high-taxed
uncompetitive jurisdictions and moving
here or to texas
same california is losing a lot of
businesses too so the same thing will
happen on a global basis
and so if you're running an asian
economy where you want to attract more
corporate dollars
you're going to keep your tax rates very
low like zug and switzerland at three
and four percent
the swiss aren't stupid they know
exactly what they're doing the whole
idea of taxing corporations is stupid
you should have zero corporate tax rates
and tax people
people don't move corporations do and so
you know you have to think about it that
way i think the corporate tax rate in
the u.s should be 15
that would be competitive it's sitting
now at a rate that's in the middle of
the g20
if biden's proposals actually were put
through
the u.s would be the highest tax
jurisdiction in the world
for corporations and the people that
lived in new york manhattan
boston massachusetts and san francisco
california
would be paying the highest tax rates of
any human being on earth
what is the likelihood that's happening
i don't think so
because i think a lot of people even in
the democratic party realize that's
unsustainable
and the other thing to realize because
i'm a policy wonk on this and i
think about this in context of investing
whoever is in the white house regardless
of party
they tend to lose seats in the midterms
so biden has to move very very quickly
to try and
jam this stuff through because he's
going to lose a lot of seats in the
midterm
that just happens naturally and there's
nothing you can do about that
any incumbent trump lost seats in the
midterm biden will lose seats
and then he'll be stymied for the rest
of his 24 months he'll be a lame duck
in that sense and i think that's the
likely outcome
so unless you can get every single
member
of the democratic party to vote for that
insane tax idea
i don't think it happens and i think
there's going to be a lot of
negotiations
because i i say insane i should be
respectful of policymakers
but to take the united states of america
and make it the least competitive
economy on earth
i think that has this chance of
happening
well china is hoping that it does happen
and that i guess the biden
administration maintains its seats in
the midterm i'm speculating here but i
think it's a safe bet
to say obviously you have actually been
quite outspoken
in terms of being more aggressive to
level the economic playing field between
the us and china that was a big priority
for the trump administration
what do you think the biden
administration
is doing to further that along or
perhaps to
unravel that i think the good news on
the byte administration is they didn't
really
unroll all of the trunk trump
initiatives on on what he did with
china he really they really worked hard
to make sure
that they would keep their feet to the
fire there's two things we need in china
and i live this every day i've got so
many investments
in in in china and other jurisdictions
as well
we need a level playing field on ip we
haven't talked about that much but
you know we need to be able to use their
court system the way they use ours
to litigate our disputes which is a
healthy thing to do
and we don't have access to that and we
also need
access to their markets their middle
class markets as they have to ours
so that and then i'd let the competition
begin you know an american technology a
product
one of my companies if i could protect
its ip
in china and sell it through
distribution there i'd like to do that
but i'm stymied because i can't litigate
there
they can here and i think we have to
level that playing field and
and i think biden understands that the
chinese are at war with us
on trying to find a digital currency we
need to lead that charge here we talked
about that earlier but
obviously china has rattled the chain
against bitcoin but may come with their
own digital one we don't know yet
we we need to prepare ourselves for a
digital currency for the us
dollar but the competition on technology
and advancing technology you know
china used to only graduate sub-par
standard engineers
today they graduate over 250 000
engineers a year that are world-class
competitive
they are doing some amazing work in all
kinds of technologies like human dna
they're working on wireless technology
that's extremely advanced
we need to compete we don't graduate 250
000 engineers we graduate great leaders
but not that many and so i think we all
have to understand it's a it's a
it's a competition and we need to hold
their standards equal to
ours and so however that gets played out
and i hope biden will
and i think he does understand it uh we
need to force their feats of fire
the chinese understand the stick they
understand the stick
and i think we have to keep using the
stick that's the one thing they respect
and i think if we do that we'll work
this out
i mean so far they haven't been held
accountable to the same standards if you
look at the world trade organization and
the way
it still regards china as a a growing
economy a developing economy if you look
for example
at the paris climate accord and china
gets all the breaks in that so when does
the rest of the world catch up with this
mentality kevin
pretty soon um i think europe's is
getting uh is
starting to understand the problem um
you know
the idea that you can herd cats to solve
the chinese problem actually doesn't
work and i'll tell you why
too much of the european economy relies
on trade with china they really don't
have much leverage
the u.s is still the world's largest
economy and it has leveraged
so this idea that we're going to do it
in unison with with the euro policy
i think is flawed it doesn't work i
think the
the last administration understood that
after 20 years of trying to negotiate
with china nothing worked
and they went out on their own and
started a policy that actually started
to get quite effective
and i think really it's the us's job to
to contain
china and bring it into a global
standard
if they want to play with the with the
rest of the world they've got to agree
to open their markets and open their ip
and open you know all of the court
system and everything else i talked
about earlier
and so i i really think it's not going
to work
you know getting the g7 you can't even
hurt those cats let alone the g20
it doesn't work it never has and so i
think it's going to have to be
biden policy delegations that keep the
american
push on it it's always helpful to have
europe behind you but they'll never lead
the charge
they can't afford to anymore china's too
big a part of their economy
all right well kevin you clearly have
very strong political opinions and as
you mentioned you've been spending a lot
of time in miami
uh which is the opposite to canada in
terms of lockdowns as we covered and
you've been quite critical of canada's
covert response
which is leading many to wonder if
you're perhaps going to do more than
just
talk about it again and perhaps enter
the political
fray again is that something on the
cards for mr wonderful
in his future i never say never to
anything but i'm so busy as an investor
today and i've got
so many projects like the crypto one we
talked about that i'm spending a lot of
time on
i'm an open critic i believe you should
be critical of government they serve you
i pay my taxes i pay a lot of tax in
canada
i pay tax the united states i i have a
vote
and i have a right and i have a right to
speak openly about what i see
as a very poorly managed country canada
is
poorly managed it can do better but i'm
very optimistic for it because no matter
how poor the management
is at the provincial and federal level
the country is so wealthy it has so many
resources that are still in the ground
that the world needs
all it needs to do is to solve for the
poor management it has
hire better managers however you have to
do that i have ideas others do too
i think canadian politicians are way
underpaid
and we can't seem to get you know
leaders that have
been successful in many sectors to come
and work as politicians
they solve for that in switzerland by
paying them well and inviting them and
making the campaign laws
easy to work with canada has a lot of of
problems there
i have brought a case uh forward to try
and break those laws down
because i've seen how they don't work
and and they keep mediocrity in
government which is terrible
and as a proud investor there as a proud
citizen and taxpayer
i would like to give back to my country
by changing those laws
and funding a federal case which i'm
doing the campaign laws are broken
the country is poorly managed the covid
pandemic
showed the weakness of canadian
management the country is a
disaster an unmitigated disaster
the fact that you have to go to prison
to visit the country
in a in a place where there's no hepa
filters where people are locked in rooms
with no air filtration
where you could get the a new you could
die there i mean the whole i that is so
insane
that that's why it's time to get the
spatula out and make the changes
that is the that's the craziest idea
i've ever seen
i feel sorry for people that are trying
to do business there
but for my canadian friends that asked
me specifically to ask you
if you will attempt a comeback to
canadian politics and rescue the country
the answer is
i i never say never anything but i will
use my
social media platform in the next
election to be an open critic
of the current management and point out
their faults their weaknesses their
failures
and hope that we as a country can can
get
better managers we simply need better
managers we are the richest country on
earth
with the smallest population managed by
very
very weak talent if you like that video
waiting to see my next one don't forget
to click right over here
and subscribe